why don't listen to me though stop for a
second I'm gonna stand up again Oh
Gustav with the camera stop up get my
ass
it's very handsome Ida [ __ ] told you
mm-hmm two [ __ ] days ago yes to watch
a documentary because we're gonna
[ __ ] watch it on the [ __ ] podcast
no that was two days ago I'm not all
right
and you did not [ __ ] watch okay can I
can I count even here you don't have to
counter bigger what you said earlier
yes when you first came in the [ __ ]
house was all know I look for it it's on
the front page of all the fun I'm not on
DirecTV I didn't have the thing or go or
whatever on the [ __ ] iPad I'm gonna
counter this was something I'm gonna
deflect the blame here yeah and I'm
gonna call back an episode of this show
that I watched where you I think it was
Eric Stonestreet and you admit it to not
watching something Amore's perros and
you want you you that's cute and
Wikipedia asked you this is what we call
deflecting blame
that's cute you're doing it's so cute I
thought about doing it about pulling a
Bobby ah like crafty is what it is my
craft is why crappy it's white craft
yeah definitely white craft for sure and
it's um shadow play working in shadow
play and also being white craft hmm and
what it is is this you're twisting it
and you're turning it and you're right
but can I say this my my house of cards
that's a very good [ __ ] point
thank you but can I just say this my
friend is okay right now when you're in
my [ __ ] submarine mmm it's a
submarine oh yeah the Rhenish a very
elephant dual purpose
it's a dual purpose it comes upside down
yeah right now is silly summer is Das
Boot
you know I have heard obscene decibels
yes yes but it's a sinking fork a
summary right now because you you you
undermine my captain sea captain
you know what it might be a word but I
don't know if it is my captain does sea
captain lady probably is but we're gonna
talk about the documentary anyway I'm
going to tell you what it's about why is
he taking notes he always does what a
professional yeah okay okay you see this
let me ask you think up captain sea
[Laughter]
keeping it in I'm not editing this
[ __ ] thing I like that strong Bobby